[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
moya lothian mclean politics editor of
galden and kate andrews economics
correspondent of the spectator welcome
to both of you and i'm very pleased to
say that they will both be with us from
now until just before midnight so let's
take a look at what's making the front
pages for tomorrow morning very very
dangerous the guardian has the pm's
warning on the build-up of russian
troops as vladimir putin sends more
units to the border with ukraine
the financial times also leads with the
ukraine crisis and telling how the
russian foreign minister has hinted at a
possible diplomatic way forward
the eye reports on what it describes as
last-ditch efforts to stop a possible
war in europe as people in kiev prepare
airaid shelters
the daily telegraph says that boris
johnson and joe biden have told russia
that the window for peace is still open
despite escalating tensions
and that's also the lead for the times
and also the mirror with the headline
last chance to stop war
the metro has boris johnson telling
european leaders to say no to their
russian gas deals
the daily mail leads with the inquiry
into the sub-post office computer
accounting scandal claiming an exclusive
with news that 33 of the victims have
died waiting for justice well the sun
has a story about a fight which broke
out after insulting personal comments
were reportedly made about the everton
and england goalkeeper jordan pickford
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you can see on screen now during
the programme you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us
so i'm joined tonight by moya lothian
mclean politics editor of galdem and
kate andrews economics correspondent of
the spectator so proper welcome to both
of you um as you might expect ukraine
dominating the front pages once again as
the tensions build up and moya you
picked up the guardian to kick us off
and they quote boris johnson's
comments today describing the situation
as very very dangerous
yes so tensions between ukraine and
russia have heightened over the last
couple of days it's an escalating
situation
and russia has sent 14 more battalions
to the ukrainian border and a brand new
show of force
and it's got to the point where in the
last few minutes uh the u.s deputy press
secretary has actually warned that an
invasion could come at any time at this
moment as the guardian's story sort of
outlines then
ministers aren't convinced yet that an
invasion will happen but uh johnson has
actually cut short a trip to cumbria
tomorrow to instead chair an emergency
cobra meeting so we're really in sort of
crunch times but people are still not
sure whether this is a real show of
brinkmanship from vladimir putin or
whether an invasion actually will go
ahead
well that's right kate and so we're
getting this sense of real tension this
sense that potentially
some kind of invasion could be imminent
and yet also if you look at the guardian
they're also suggesting that this even
though the number of troops is
increasing on the borders according to
this report it could be that they're
prepared to stay there for some months
yeah this is one of the real
difficulties of the situation is that if
putin does want to invade ukraine he is
now in a position to do so with
roughly estimated up to 150 000 troops
in russia on that ukrainian border but
he could be pulling back troops he could
wait days weeks months if he actually
plans to make a move
and no one's sure what his plan is
there's speculation that even vladimir
putin doesn't quite know what he wants
to do yet one thing he will have noticed
while the west has in many ways been
slow to get their ducks in a row there
is more and more agreement amongst
western powers about the seriousness of
this situation and if putin were to
march his troops into ukraine there's
certainly a sense now that the west
would unite even more so and cause a
real economic headache at the very least
for putin so um there are certainly
drawbacks to taking that military action
he is definitely in a place to do it
however which is why these diplomatic
discussions are so crucial now to try to
de-escalate the situation which if he
wanted to give the green light to could
cause real pain and almost no doubt many
deaths well yes when you talk about
diplomacy if we move on to the daily
telegraph that's their main headline
window for peace is open say biden and
johnson boris johnson had a call with
the american president earlier on this
evening we're told they agreed there
remained a crucial window for diplomacy
and for russia to step back from its
threats towards ukraine and moya we did
get a little sense of perhaps some
movement in that russia
did seem to hint that a diplomatic
solution was still possible so
how much of a sense of optimism are you
getting from the papers that this could
be
some kind of invasion could be pushed
back
well as as you've pointed out this is
the report from the telegraph on sort of
this last ditch real frantic diplomacy
efforts from the west but they're not
the only ones who are leaving that
window open there was a very staged
press conference yesterday between
vladimir putin one of his high-ranking
ministers who said they were still very
much open and wanted to expand diplomacy
efforts and in fact the ukrainian
ambassador pristiko said that they would
consider dropping a nato bid um when
appearing on i think radio 4's today
program this was quickly pooh-poohed by
his own president zelinski but the fact
that it was even said in the first place
says that perhaps the um efforts of
russia the show of force is making a
difference in that uh
in in the sort of resistance that
ukraine had to this but the western said
they absolutely will not consider any
sort of bullying tactics and that
ukraine have a full right to join nato
so it is still really a stalemate well
yes and kate what is in the west's
armory when it comes to putting pressure
on president putin we've got the german
chancellor visiting tomorrow
they're talking about a significant
package of sanctions but but what's
likely to make a difference
well there's a whole host of action that
the west could take that wouldn't
involve military intervention economic
sanctions are obviously at the top of
that list and there is already talk of
cutting russia out of major major
markets which could cause a huge amount
of pain um to the country uh but part of
the problem at the moment is that there
still isn't full agreement between say
the us the uk and germany about what
that action might look like and this
comes down to that fundamental pipeline
north stream to that gas pipeline
that russia is desperate to see go ahead
that the germans at the moment still are
very keen to have but recognize that's
becoming more and more politically
difficult this is one of the
difficulties for the west it isn't just
for germany it's for all of us but
certain european countries will fill it
even more acutely if we were to cut
russia off economically it would hurt
russia very badly but energy prices uh
in the uk and across europe and the rest
west would also soar as so many
countries are dependent on that we're
already seeing energy bills go up it's
already becoming a very difficult
situation in domestic politics talking
about those energy bills i mean my gosh
you have the chancellor bailing out 80
of households over the next year uh
through council tax cuts in order to
help subsidize their energy bills so
they're going to be economic
consequences for everyone if that's the
route that we take but many people agree
that that's more preferable than to say
actually going in with military action
and then the other big question mark
over this is is the concept of cyber
warfare something and that would be
quite new in this almost cold war style
standoff that you wouldn't necessarily
see boots on the ground but you would
see direct attacks on banks on the
internet on electricity and the rest of
it i mean this is if things really
escalate this is getting you know far
worse we still don't know if putin's
really going to take action but these
are the kinds of things that people are
mulling over now um as as we wonder what
kind of action the west might take if
putin were to uh move his military into
ukraine well yes and moya what do you
make of this the energy issue the fact
that germany does have this deal the
north stream pipeline which would
connect russia with germany they could
pull out of that deal couldn't they olaf
schultz visiting a president putin
tomorrow
what impact do you think that could have
well i'm not an expert on energy or the
sort of the energy politics to be honest
with you so i don't think i can speak on
this extensively but i think any sort of
sanctions or ramifications will have
massive economic consequences for the
entirety of europe and we're already
seeing a cost of living crisis here
based on
existing russian
aggressiveness in ukraine
and the predicted prices of energy next
year even though we don't get our energy
direct from russia it's already had an
impact on the prices for this year and
next year um so
all i see in the future is is higher
prices and more misery but if sanctions
are what it takes um then sanctions are
what it's going to have to be
and let's move on to the eye shall we
okay because they also lead with ukraine
their headline is last ditch efforts to
stop war in europe and and as usual with
the eye you've got a series of bullet
points on their front page and they talk
about residents of kiev and their top
one preparing air raid shelters as
russia suggests that dialogue is still
possible that's their top headline there
and it's really interesting to see what
reaction there is within ukraine because
while there's been a lot of talk in the
west about the the potential imminence
of an invasion uh people in ukraine
carrying on life as normal
well yes of course and it's a it's a
very brave thing that they're doing and
this is one of the difficulties for
vladimir putin as he considers his next
moves is that if he were to send 150 000
troops into ukraine um he won't just be
dealing with the pushback from the west
the economic sanctions nato probably
increasing its power increasing defense
spending and however that manifests
itself but he'll also be looking at
pushback from the ukrainians and it's
very difficult to see a scenario where
putin doesn't then have to commit to
having boots on the ground in ukraine
actually staging a real occupation
because there would be so much pushback
from the public another bullet point on
the front page bi is talking about how
many people could be displaced based off
uh more serious actions from putin it
estimates up to a million people um a
very very important reminder of the
knock-on effect that this is going to
have um certainly not just in ukraine
but across europe yeah what do you make
of that maya
yes um so this was actually a story that
was reported yesterday as well from the
eye further on and it was talking about
uh the measures that eastern european
leaders are going to to prepare for a
potential refugee crisis and poland say
they're uh preparing for the worst case
possible scenario um whitehall are
drawing up plans to try and avoid the
sort of crisis we saw earlier this year
in belarus when you had thousands of
migrants trapped on the border in
freezing temperatures um but even a
small-scale sort of invasion any sort of
action
is looks to result in least thousands of
displaced people um so there's going to
have to be policy put in place to
prepare for that and you know the europe
is already dealing with a refugee crisis
and not dealing with it very well the uk
especially is quite poorly um responding
to the current refugee crisis
um on its borders by instead providing
more sanctions against asylum seekers
and people and refugees so uh i i think
there's going to be the story is not
going away basically and i just want to
pick up something kate said as well
about popular insurgency in ukraine um
it's something we saw very clearly with
iraq and the uk viewer at the moment is
that there is likely to be a very
reasonably well organized insurgency if
russia invades and that what russia
thinks is a quick shock-and-awe regime
change will instead claim thousands tens
of thousands of lives
and picking up on the issue of potential
migration as a result of any action um
you've picked out the opinion page of
the financial times kate which focuses
on asylum seekers so what's their line
in this
yeah i just thought this was a really
interesting comment piece from sarah
o'connor in the financial times it's
extremely personal given the fact that
we're talking about possible
displacement in ukraine again in one of
the worst case scenarios but it's
relevant regardless especially with the
refugees who have been coming from
afghanistan and it is addressing what
moya was pointing to there just the fact
that the uk is really so far behind on
on the rights that it gives refugees
while they're waiting to find out their
status in the uk um and it's interesting
that this is the employment column
because it's talking about how we have a
serious labor crunch in the uk and we
still have this very outdated model with
the refugee system in which refugees are
not allowed to work while they're
waiting for their status despite the
fact that so many of them want to work
want to contribute and don't want to be
living off the tax money and off the
state they want to be earning their own
income so it seems like a win-win
opportunity here
that the refugees that we already have
coming and let's pray frankly that the
ukraine situation de-escalates and we
don't have further displacement but
goodness forbid whatever happens if and
when refugees do come to the uk that
they have the right to work while they
wait for that status it's good for the
taxpayer it's good for them and it's
really good especially when they are
settled in the uk that they already have
um that step up that they're already on
the employment ladder that they're
already immersing into society okay
we're going to take a pause right there
but plenty more to talk about coming up
after the break so don't go away
including how many people will be fined
over partygate why the metropolitan
police is planning to tell us that's
coming up
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview and with me tonight moya lovian
mclean politics editor of geldam and
kate andrews economics correspondent of
the spectator so welcome back to youtube
um so there are other stories around
although the front pages are largely
dominated by the situation in ukraine
and kate you've picked out a story on
the front of the daily telegraph and a
reminder that
we don't have the party gate issues all
resolved yet but what's the met police
say
well partygate rumbles on and this is an
update from the met police that it is
expected to disclose the number of
people who end up getting fined for
parties that were not supposed to take
place in downing street over lockdown
but it also quite clearly says that they
don't plan to name any of those people
specifically um so this is an update
that many people have been looking for
what exactly is the met police going to
be reporting on uh their decision to
wade into these scandals uh means that
uh the information has been delayed but
it's also obviously up the ante so
another piece of information as we wait
for the final results well that's right
so that's one to keep an eye on and one
we will no doubt be hearing a lot about
when we do get some of those results but
let's move on because we don't have huge
amount of time in this section i do want
to get to some of the other front pages
moya the daily mails front page focuses
on the public inquiry which opened today
into the post office scandal that saw uh
subpost masters and mistresses wrongly
convicted for fraud and already we've
heard an awful lot about ruined lives
and um
the headline is very stark 33 die
without justice in post office scandal
yes so this is 33 victims of the scandal
who have died before the inquiry even
started and these deaths are actually in
addition uh to for individuals who
believed to have taken their own lives
linked with the scandal scandal and 15
more who died who were also part of a
separate high court action and this
story is going to rumble on and on and
on because as we've seen already the
testimony from those affected is
devastating the post office is obviously
sort of a great british institution
and it's a story that really points to
the role of computer systems and
automated systems where trust is putting
them over the testimony of people and
it's it's in a way it's very modern so
it's not going anywhere and we're going
to see more of this sort of stuff come
out from it and there are some terrible
human stories aren't there kate that
have emerged from this of lives really
ruined
oh it's absolutely awful described as uh
one of the worst miscarriages of justice
in in recent legal history and it really
does seem that way when you think about
people many of whom will have been
completely innocent um being accused of
committing you know really terrible
crimes and being punished for them and
many people going without any justice at
all it's absolutely harrowing and to
think that a tax system um could have
could have so um wrongly ended up
accusing these people of crimes they
didn't commit is is really quite
frightening
and a quick look at the guardian their
front page again devoted to ukraine but
the second headline on their front page
moyer is about the uk being urged i
think it's by a french diplomat who was
involved in the uh paris climate accord
so a key figure there putting pressure
on the uk
to
defy what they're saying in inverted
commerce on the front page culture war
attacks on net zero
yes so this is this is further linked to
the infamous net zero security group
which is uh made up mostly of a group of
conservative
politicians who've been trying recently
to link the net zero agenda to the cost
of living crisis and argue that we
should cut green taxes and we should
increase fossil fuel production in order
to tackle this this is obviously
completely false in fact um pursuing a
sustainable agenda would help with the
cost of living crisis
but um this the the french politicians
are saying we cannot allow ourselves to
bring um our net zero goals into the
culture war okay and i totally agree uh
kate um those who argue for the um
the green levees to go would say
people's bills are already very high the
cost of living is high if we take those
levees off now it gives them a bit of a
reprieve
yeah so i agree with moya that in you
know the ideal world that i think we can
probably achieve over the next few
decades a greener society is hopefully
going to be a cheaper one the difficulty
is that transition and at the moment
there is no denying when you look at the
breakdown of people's bills that green
loving levies are contributing you know
by no means the majority but quite a
substantial few hundred pounds of that
and at the moment with energy bills
going up so much that's that's really
quite
meaningful and they're also quite
complicated i mean if you really do want
to be taxing um carbon output in the
rest of it perhaps you should be looking
at something more simplistic and more
direct like a carbon tax rather than
just throwing levy and levy on top of
energy bills that ultimately the
consumer's going to have to pay